welcome back everyone we're back with
Lisa Sara and Charlie and they got some
important points to make let's start
with you Charlie yeah look Steve in your
book you taught me the power of
decentralization are looking at things
on a local level
we're starting to see where this is
really concentrated you have about 20%
of the u.s. population in New Jersey New
York and California specifically in LA
County in New York City they're
accounting for about 59% of the cases so
they're punching way above the weight of
the even population percentage they have
the country and so what I'd like to see
is an even heavier focus and more
national unity about assisting those
areas and also relieving some of the
quarantine and allowing the American
entrepreneur to be liberated de 15 comes
some of the other parts of the country
that have not been as impacted because
you talked about there are real economic
consequences to these sorts of
quarantines that have been going on yeah
exactly this blanket shot down over
everywhere great great point Lisa you
had a reaction to Larry Cutler's
comments earlier I almost jumped out of
my seat when he said potentially 12
weeks I mean will any of these policy
prescriptions that Congress and the
White House are working on going to
matter at that point Bank of America
estimates that by next week we could see
three million unemployment claims so it
seems to me it's more critical for the
White House in Congress to work with
public health officials to figure out
how do you slow slow the spread of the
corona virus and protect vulnerable
communities and individuals without
uttering the economy because does anyone
actually think 12 weeks of this is not
going to completely destroy the economy
that's era that's such an important
point I mean Lisa has a very important
important point here and this is
something that the administration I'm
sure is looking at very closely
something that they are going to deal
with in this 15 day mark when it comes
up and it's something they have to deal
with we all do but I think the important
things Steve is that we we all have
common sense we use that common sense we
know how to take care of ourselves and
our loved ones we listen to the medical
professionals but we use our common
sense and find a way to not only curb
the coronavirus but also ensure that our
economy doesn't come crashing down I
believe that the American people can
weather this storm and that we will
forward and that we will be victorious
in this but we can only do that with
common sense and just just in the few
seconds that are left Charlie I'd just
like you to wrap it up in terms of how
we go it'll come together over this and
stop the political attacks some of the
commentary you're hearing from the media
using it as an excuse to attack
president trim that's got a stop don't
you think yeah it's nonsense look the
president is in a phenomenal job and I
can tell you the president has been the
monkees adapted quick into quick
leadership form almost like wartime for
him quicker than any other president we
could have possibly imagined he has
brought the country together against an
invisible enemy and I'm telling you the
president will make the right decisions
to get this economy back and roaring in
in quick order and he will be able to
allocate the resources needed in these
parts of the country I'd need them and
he will liberate the American off yeah
well thank you for that thank you Lisa
thank you Sarah great discussion tonight
thank you for joining us and do please
come back again next Sunday when the
next revolution will be televised